now
labor's shadow foreign secretary david
lammy he's giving a speech on the
northern ireland protocol to the tuc
congress in central london uh let's have
a listen nato allies against
dictatorship against imperialism
in defense of freedom ready to provide
the military economic diplomatic and
humanitarian assistance that ukraine so
badly needs
kirsten was labor is crystal clear
there is no place
in our party
for the false equivalence between
putin's aggression
and nato's desire for peace through
collective security and common defense
[Applause]
but we must also focus on the longer
term because this conflict could go on
for months
and years
we must rewrite our foreign policy
priorities to learn from the
conservatives mistakes
the government's integrated review
wrongly de-emphasized european security
while they wasted billions
of pounds of the defense budget in
government labor would halt planned cuts
to the british army
frankly it's extraordinary in these
times that cuts are going ahead not only
this we would put past brexit divisions
behind us and finally make brexit work
end boris's era of clumsy diplomacy and
use this new moment to rebuild relations
with european allies through a new
uk eu security pact
the government appears poised
to do the opposite
to unilaterally break
the agreement
that they negotiated
they signed and they were elected on
instead of finding practical solutions
they're planning a trade war
in a cost of living
crisis
making brexit works takes statecraft
it takes diligence
and graft
not boris johnson's clumsy wrecking ball
people in northern ireland deserve a
responsible government
but instead we have a prime minister who
can't be trusted and a government
willing to break international law
the implications of this go far beyond
the checks and barriers in the irish sea
the government has repeatedly called on
other countries to abide by
international law and stick up to their
commitments
be that iran
on the nuclear agreement
china and the joint declaration on hong
kong
or russia and the budapest memorandum
it's damaging
to britain's reputation
to our country's credibility and its
moral authority
if we renege on our own agreements
do we want to make other countries
hesitate when signing deals with us
out of fear that we won't keep our end
of the bargain
britain should be a country that keeps
its words
this reflects on who we are
the nation that stands for the rule of
law
the best ways to stand up for
international law
and to follow it
and this comes at the worst possible
time europe is facing the most serious
security crisis in a
generation there is war on our continent
millions have fled from their homes
countries have pulled together in
support of ukraine it is wrong
short-sighted and ill-judged
to seek divisions with our european
allies as we face this common threat
but as well as defending europe
from the dictator on our doorsteps we
must not forget
that there are other conflicts and
crises around the world
afghanistan has been out of our
headlines since february's invasion that
millions
face starvation
in yemen one of the world's worst
humanitarian crisis
prices of essential food products are up
81
and the israeli palestinian conflict
continues to lead to a heartbreaking
loss of life and the killing
of the journalists shireen abu aklay and
the disgraceful scenes at her funeral
remind us that we will not there will
not be a just and lasting peace
until the occupation is brought to an
end and both israelis and palestinians
enjoy
dignity security
human rights
and are part of a two-state solution
[Applause]
and in the horn of africa the horrific
drought
that's currently taking hold
could put 20 million lives at risk
soaring food prices and shortages
threaten a global humanitarian
catastrophe
labor would lead from the front to help
to stop this
working with the united nations to
organize an emergency global food summit
to put food security at the very top of
the agenda under the conservatives
britain has stepped back from its former
leadership role cutting billions in aid
mismanaging the merger of our
development and foreign office
leaving them less frankly than the sum
of their parts
it's now almost two years since the
prime minister announced that merger but
the scdo still has no clear aid strategy
governance or funding settlement this
leaves us unable to deliver on the
global stage no wonder staff morale in
that department is at breaking point a
labour government would restore the
naught point seven percent aid target
because while ukraine needs all the
support we can give it it would be
foolish to ignore other conflicts around
the world storing up problems for the
future and ignoring mass loss of life
restoring 0.7 will give the foreign
office the flexibility it needs to step
up now in the time to rebuild
our soft power and be a beacon for our
values around the world
energy prices are already going through
the roof but we need to prepare for a
further spike as europe heads into this
next winter ahead we can and must
end our dependence on dirty fossil fuels
our prime minister's strategy
is to fill the gaps
of russian energy
by finding new authoritarians to deal
with and to beg them for oil instead
whether it's iran or saudi arabia this
is short-term thinking
it goes against the progressive values
that we hold and it fails frankly to
learn the lessons of putin fossil fuels
empower the worst dictators
the only progressive form
of energy independence is through clean
energy and that is why a labor
government in britain would invest in a
green recovery with 28 billion pounds a
year
in green investment this decade
conference
a progressive britain needs a
progressive foreign policy
one rooted in the values we believe in
the virtues we wish to promote
for too many years we've been governed
by a party who has made foreign policy
transactional
making short-term calculations and often
frankly getting their sums wrong with
labour the uk would finally have a
foreign policy on which we could be
proud
rooting out corruption and foreign
interference in our economy defending
the security of our conf of our
continent strengthening the institutions
and alliances that protect us standing
up for our principles
here and abroad
investing in green technology for future
generations and aid for those facing
starvation and conflict not only because
this makes us safer but because it's the
right thing to do
together
we can make an international britain
fit for this country once again
thank you
wow we shall also leave that there that
is the shadow foreign secretary david
lammy effectively laying out labor's a
stall on foreign policy should they be
the party
of government says that europe is facing
the most serious security crisis in a
generation and that we must prepare that
the conflict in ukraine may go on for a
long time also made a big pitch
for clean energy
and looking out for matters such as food
security uh for the rest of the world
particularly developing countries
david lammy there addressing the trades
union congress in central london